aber warum ich kümmere mich jetzt seit
drei folgen also nur um diese fahne
wovon wir nachher alle profitieren ich
bin so sozial
nicht mit neuen sounds vor allem immer
nur leicht nach oben laufen es gibt
natürlich immer ein paar sachen nähe das
gerade hatte ich immer ein paar sachen
wo man sagt naja das braucht man nicht
aber für ein paar andere leute die
finden das wiederum gut und ich war
wirklich vor ein paar wochen oder vor
einem monat oder so echt noch so von
wegen
minecraft in die komplett falsche sache
richtung aber ich meine wie wollen sie
sonst die ganzen leute halten bei dem
spiel zeichner die müssen ja quasi mal
was neues bringen deswegen ist es
eigentlich schon ganz gut dass die da so
ein paar sachen einfügen wie zum
beispiel brauen oder sowas und von
irgendwelchen ganz gut
denkst du ja gleich ich bin wenn ich du
warst du beim gewesen dass du dir nichts
genommen oder mira genannt ich habe aber
nur noch glasscheibe noch nicht allzu
viel wird als ein
ja das wird nicht die farm wird richtig
groß alter da kommt noch mehr lohn
kürbisse kartoffeln karotten und so was
alles hier noch andere tiere wissen ist
macht sehen das wird richtig richtig
großprojekt den hast du erde für mich da
wir als christ sind können wir auch mal
wieder ein bisschen zusammen handeln das
urteil dagegen verkauf finden wien
höchsten sowieso ein dorfbewohner 35 bis
50 smart die kriegst einen stack hat er
heftig mit überwälder selber was ist ein
tableau aber keine erde nimmt er das
risiko lieber selber auf sich zu klauen
es gibt erfasst werde 64 oder so aber
okay gut ich hab die lustige sachen
gegeben du könntest ja ich kann dir
unbedingt die guten kartoffeln gegeben
ja aber dafür michael kremmel gegeben
dann habe ich dir auch wieder ein
bisschen dinge gegeben apple store
dafür hast du mir gar nichts gegeben ok
ich komme jetzt heißt wir wären dann
mehr als gegeben
jetzt ist meine ich wollte erst
argumentieren dafür dass es auf jeden
fall kriegen
mit dem schädel bearbeiten kann ein
schönes stückchen leder vom leder
zu den hier bei der farm das sieht also
krass ausgabe will man mir ausgang
borisow nachher alles so groß aussehen
wenn ihr so 10 milliarden stehen das
wird richtig geil ist doch klar
schlucker ich habe nicht mal sand und
wenn ich zeit hätte würde ich das nicht
wert schon einsammeln danke für euer ja
verständlich ständig ja panik
wir sind jetzt bei einer stunde 20
minuten hatten wir jetzt in dieser folge
zum thema alter und denkt so gut doch
nie ehrlich sagen wir es mal zeit dass
oder was hatten wir was war setzte thema
wir hatten gar kein thema lena wusste
ein glas entwicklung zum beispiel wollte
ich jetzt doch keins doch wie hyper
brauchst du normal so der glasscheiben
hast du noch normales das ja schon mal
ein thema das thema wie es von minecraft
und zwar darf eine moschee höher als ein
kirchenturm sein
ehrlich gesagt scheißegal doch damals
auch so also ich mach das jetzt einmal
gedient anfangen ich weiß dass es damals
auch so war im mittelalter oder ein
bisschen später jetzige ganz genauen
zeiten folgen dabei es keine ahnung
jedenfalls war es damals die kirche das
höchste gebäude der stadt sein musste
und dass alle straßen zur kirche hin
führen
ich finde das einfach alles total
bescheuert was da mittlerweile oder
auch damals für religionen sage ich mal
ist aber mit unserem europäischen raum
so gewesen
im orientalischen raum war komplett
anders naja aber allgemein so was da für
religion alles gemacht wenn ich mein
wenn leute glauben wollen dann sollen
sie es tun und damit das ist jetzt nicht
unbedingt von auch erstmal ausschlag
geben dass seine kirche unbedingt so
groß sein muss damit gott darin platz
hat oder so also ich finde das ist egal
denn die moschee größer bauen wollen
endlich christen damals egal sein das
kommt dem regime unter gross sein
vor allem geht es im taumel also kirche
mir aber nur darum dass man seine sein
glaubt tritt und schmeißt man claudia so
glauben was er möchte
genau schöne worte ja ich hab jetzt
absolut kein problem damit von
irgendjemanden aber trotzdem ist das
problem wenn so ein kleines ganz
beschauliches wohnviertel jetzt von von
weiß ich jetzt zum beispiel in köln war
das hätte ich auch zum beispiel in
deutschland das problem ganz hoch
geschaukelt in der schweiz per
volksabstimmung verboten haben dass sie
gebaut werden überhaupt komplett aber
das dann halt irgendwelche leute wurden
die komplett christlich ist diese
komplette leute der wohnungen wird eine
moschee hin gebaut und die alle anteil
gebäude in der umgebung überragt und wo
dann auch sonntags der partie wie heißt
das die leute dann da ausrufen
das habe ich oder 3 das hört sich eher
jüdisch an die leute die an keinen
kirchenglocken sondern die haben da halt
irgendjemanden da oben stehen und werden
zum gebet ruft auf arabische larissa und
jetzt hats nicht und alle muslimischen
mit zuschauer
ja das sowieso aber das würde mich jetzt
auch stirn
ehrlich gesagt aber mich würde auch
stimmen wenn eine neue kirche gebaut
wird und plötzlich jeden sonntag die
glocken da kommen also ich habe da jetzt
einfach ein allgemeines problem mit also
nicht das problem sozusagen liegt sich
an der moschee weil es ja und ich glaube
sie ist stört beispielsweise aber
ansonsten eigentlich alles roger so ist
das bei mir zumindest dass ihr ziemlich
anti religiös eingestellt wenn also wenn
jemand seinen glauben mag ist okay aber
damit möchte ich dann nichts zu tun
haben also komplett freie
religionsausübung jeder davon das
glauben was er will aber das soll nicht
alles in der öffentlich an die fw in der
öffentlichkeit so praktiziert werden
dass andere davon gestört werden
und ich finde eine moschee oder eine
kirche die der jeden sonntag oder
häufiger ihre kirchenglocken läuten
naja ist der von ihm der ausruf das
gemacht finde ich nicht gut
aber da wir halt kirche christlich
geprägt sind wir sind halt mit den
kirchen ist es für uns eine
selbstverständlichkeit geworden aber ich
glaube da bist du auch somit der einzige
der so denkt weil du beschreibst das
gerade so ja wenn ich da nicht für bin
und wenn ich gerade nicht glaube dann
nervt mich das einfach nur aber ich
meine es ist ja auch so dass zum
beispiel setzen weit hergeholt ist
beispiel aber wenn zb leute neben dem
fußballstadion wohnen und die
interessiert sich gar nicht vorkommt
dann immer sonst so pfiff und die
zuschauer also es gibt sehr deutscher
werden den im fußballstadion dass ich
aus russland oder hinziehen
es ist in russland in fast jedem stadion
so dass dann eben leute wohnen
ich meine du kannst du hier in seine
kirche ist oder so dass er arbeitete das
auch einfach gebaut wird nicht auf die
bewohner rücksicht genommen und
deutschland ein stadion bauen willst
adresse aber werden die anwohner aber
sturm laufen also schon mal im
kindergarten so extrem
da wären demonstration macht keine
kinder bei uns ein kleiner platz 19
jetzt wirklich aufgefallen ich läute
kann sich hier so hätte ich meine bei
mir ist das scheißegal ob der nachbar
über mir 24 stunden poltert meine ich
mache auch irgendwann mein tag und ich
hoffe es nicht was er macht
was ich war sind beide froh so zu sagen
bei uns allein in der wohnung mein
bruder fuzzy g also in der nähe der uni
ganz billig deswegen ist mega entspannt
ich könnte mich da so mit beschwerden
zum thema das constanze stempel sie zu
fuß oder was weiß ich was ich würde mich
beschwert weil ich das noch nicht erlebt
habe gesagt dass in diesem lande die
auslosung habe ich noch nicht erlebt ich
weiß nicht wie das ist ich hab selber
musiker und ich erlebe ich mich nur die
betrachtungsweisen die pen der leute die
dort wohnen
ich bin ins bett
okay was halt nicht immer so schwarz
weiß ich da mal aus versehen ein
falsches wort in den mund nimmt dann
bist du direkt tot
da kann für praktisch schon direkt fünf
minuten auf die uhr gucken ein drittel
direkt geklopft aber da draußen
geschleppt und wer schon karikaturen von
mohammed zu machen oder allgemeinen
kinofilm darzustellen man darf sicher
kein bildnis von gott macht darf man
doch auch im beim christentum nicht oder
darf man eigentlich auch nicht aber das
wird immer wieder gemacht wer richtig
also und das ist halt das problem ist
halt dass das religion hinter sehr
streng
naja dass das bei einem christentum mir
auch so vor 500 jahren 100 jahren ja im
mittelalter aber wahr sein status ist
aber das ist der islam noch natürlich
viele moderne viele viele moderne
viele viele moderne moslems aber auch
kraß viele die halt noch ihre religion
ausüben wie wie es im mittelalter getan
haben das ist ja das problem eigentlich
wenn man muss ja sagen damit gab es auch
diese ablassbriefe pascal ist okay jetzt
trifft ihn wieder zu sehen
das ist jetzt wieder es ist jetzt
allgemein glaube existiert oder
existiert hier nicht das haben wir auch
schon alles gemacht bei dem thema das
hat mir glaub ich in der zehnten folge
das urknall oder entstehungsgeschichte
einem jahr wieder angefangen religiös zu
zweifeln und ab man kann ja einfach wenn
dazu noch klärungsbedarf steht statt
auch in die kommentare ob ihr aber
spezifische fragen wie findet ina oder
das oder sofa allgemein kann man darüber
sich tot genauso wie wie findet ihr nur
soziale netzwerke ist auch so eine sache
das ist wirklich zu grob sagen einfach
der song lang genau dieses variablen ich
finde es eigentlich so grobe themen ganz
okay weil man da halt eigentlich ist
ausschalten kann und das ja eigentlich
auch richtig ist als wenn man nur so
eine mini teilaspekt dann betrachtet
würde so fange dass das fand ich gut
dass das nicht fertig und dann gestellt
aber ich finde schon wenn man jetzt so
sachen schreibt zum beispiel ein land in
den kommentaren existiert gott oder
nicht anerkannt sich eine theoretisch
eine stunde zwei stunden drei tage
dauerten diskutieren oder wäre es für
mich auch eine lösung kommt dass er
genau wir haben jetzt alle unsere
meinung gesagt und so richtig auf den
löwen leben gekommen lösung können wir
sowieso nicht unsere meinung lesen auch
ganz gut dass wir hier nur diskutieren
und nicht wirklich eine lösung hervor
bringen weil sonst so heißt die drei
länder die sind dafür und da bin ich
nicht für und die hast dich jetzt und
keine ahnung
oh ja
wir wollten sich eigentlich einmal rum
führen wir am anfang der aufnahmesession
achso damit ihr zeigt was alles gemacht
haben fragen bevor wir einfach gehen
zeigt ich alles anders zum ende zog er
in den zwei stunden auf dem desktop eine
stunde 30
mein haus ist schon richtig geil ich
will unbedingt fertig kriegen habt ihr
noch kabel damaligen halbe stunde ich
würde dir gleich helfen zu fahren
ich würde dann sogleich mal so rum
kommen
komplett wird das immer bei meinem haus
so komisch aber warum alter ich kümmere
mich jetzt drei folgen also nur um diese
fahne wovon wir nachher alle profitieren
ich bin so sozial erste social nicht
socialis ja ich halte deswegen euch das
gesagt ich wusste dass wir sachen
einstellung ja gar nicht dass es so
fantastisch was hat sie da wirklich
hatten richtig schönen satzes braun lena
pack eigentlich dass marina kräftig
häfen
januar spielt das holz ausgetauscht also
das häufig richtig schön aus das ist man
das dunkle fichtenholz
das ist mir bearbeiteten sieht nicht
schlecht aus
ich habe im moment so eine beta version
vom den apec 1.4 ist noch nicht fertig
also wenn du irgendwann wenn ihr euch
fragt ist das noch nicht so habe ich es
meisterlich gehen
ja ja so mache ich das problem bei mir
ist mein haus hier an zuschauer muss ihm
erst mal so ein riesenberg runter laufen
um zu gucken wo ich bin
es gab auch nicht die ganze zeit erde
gefahren blogger eine folge lang das
reicht jetzt hat man dafür dass sich
fünf in etwas aufstocken kann
aber es wird es wird aus ist gar nicht
mehr so viel das ist ja gut es aber
immer so
ich verstehe nicht was ich da gebaut
etwas das es so komisch ist man was ist
da eis weil sie mal muss das ist jetzt
die lösung aller probleme sei ich euch
jetzt habe ich das dach fertig dann
gleich im c quadrat heller habe ich auch
schon dann auch wenn jetzt nur noch eine
halbe stunde haben wir jetzt schon nur
noch 20 minuten dieser folge dort weiß
ich dann erneuten immer wir uns um das
stadthaus kümmern also von mir aus
können wir gerne zweieinhalb stunden
machen mir ist es relativ egal wenn du
flexibel
ich habe morgen zu dritten neues thema
echt jetzt schon wir haben doch fit
schon leer sind bei eine stunde 32 sind
jetzt zwei minuten erfolgen wenn man ein
bisschen umherschweifen dann passt das
ganz genau mit was ich hab euch noch was
bei mir ja transfers haben alles floss
müsstest du her kommen
alles klar kommst du ja gleich schon da